seguro ya resuelto muchas ecuaciones de
primer o segundo grado aplicando la
fórmula general factor izando o quizás
de alguna otra manera
te presento el siguiente ejemplo y vamos
a resolverlo juntos tratando de
encontrar la mejor solución
- x al cuadrado
2x menos 4 igual a cero utilicemos la
fórmula general para ecuaciones de
segundo grado x es igual a menos b más
menos raíz cuadrada debe al cuadrado
menos 4 hace todo entre 2 y sabemos que
la manera de resolver esta ecuación es
sustituyendo sus elementos en la fórmula
así que empecemos a es el coeficiente
que acompaña a la x cuadrada b el que
acompaña a la x lineal y c es el término
independiente por lo tanto a vale menos
1 b vale más 2 y c es igual a menos 4 si
sustituimos estos valores en la fórmula
x es igual a menos 2 + menos raíz
cuadrada de 2 al cuadrado menos 4 x
menos 1 x menos 4 todo esto entre 2 x
menos 1
entonces menos por 2 es igual a menos 2
más menos raíz cuadrada de 2 al cuadrado
es 4
ahora vamos a multiplicar los signos
menos por menos da más y otra vez por
menos es menos tenemos 4 por 1 4 por 4
16 así que escribimos menos 16 y en el
divisor 2 por menos 1 es igual a menos 2
entonces la operación que sigue por
simplificar es 4 16 qué resultado
obtenemos
-12 está un poco raro fíjate muy bien
tenemos una raíz cuadrada negativa y eso
no se puede resolver así que es
inadmisible qué quiere decir esto quiere
decir que es una ecuación que
simplemente no tiene solución y aunque
seas un genio en matemáticas -12 no
tiene raíz siempre que multiplicamos un
número por sí mismo tendremos un
resultado positivo aunque éste sea
negativo
recuerda que menos x menos es igual a
más por lo tanto esta ecuación ni
pitágoras podría resolverla así que
cuando veas ecuaciones como ésta donde
ya no puede simplificar más considera
este como tu resultado veamos unos
ejemplos muy sencillos y rápidos donde
también hay resultados inadmisibles
tenemos f x es igual a 2 entre x
si le asignamos x cualquier valor
distinto de 0 obtenemos algún resultado
para f x
pero cuando x vale 0 tenemos una
indeterminación porque no se puede
dividir ningún número entre 0 esto
quiere decir que al graficar no habrá
ningún punto que pase por el 0 en x 1
más
f x es igual a raíz de x si x la
sustituimos por 0 o por cualquier número
positivo no habrá ningún inconveniente
pero si por alguna razón se sustituye
por un número negativo tendremos un
problema porque como ya viste las raíces
cuadradas negativas no existen
de la misma forma esto nos indica que al
graficar la función no habrá ningún
punto que se ubique en el lado negativo
de x
así que recuerda que cuando tenemos
ecuaciones que por más que intentemos
resolverlas no encontramos la solución
decimos que son resultados inadmisibles